what oh my God this one's so bad burn it
hey I'm Huddy and today I'm gonna be
reading thirst tweets
I have literally no idea what people say
about me online
I'm nervous oh no oh my God we're
already off to a gnarly start yeah sex
is good but have you ever listened to
hoodie's new song True okay I I've read
the word sex I thought this was gonna go
like somewhere crazy yeah it's not that
bad have you ever had sex while
listening to a hottie song is the is the
real question oh this one's sweet
actually little honey is the most
beautiful man in tick tock not on it's
in I'm inside of tick tock I live there
wow this one's long OMFG look at every
detail of him the eyebrows the eyebrows
the eyes the nose the lips and the hair
Chase Hudson you're perfect in every
single detail I have no more compliments
for you wow damn okay none of these have
been too bad so far I'm like
thank God I would like to pre-face this
by saying the I too am disappointed in
myself but I would absolutely encourage
vampire little honey to bite me help
nobody and this is nothing literally not
a single soul
still nothing not even their mom me
the way Chase Hudson inhales air is so
sexy uh thanks
I'd let Chase Hudson call me repulsive
Trista you are so repulsive I'd let
Hardy tap it only if he was fresh out of
the barbershop
actually I'm I'm pretty fresh at the
barbershop I'm not gonna lie I got my
hair done today too so you know what's
up I would like Chase Hudson she
referred to me by my name how sweet I
would like Chase Hudson to shove his
tongue down my throat okay good night
she's such a way with words thank you
Meg I appreciate it uh oh
okay she was put out loud damn just
another day of being horny for honey
perfect sentence Chase Hudson can have
my children no cap on god Loki High key
and then
a shitload of letters how many four how
many kids we talking okay I can't even
this this one says I know little hottie
is an army so respectfully he can hold
my left nut what
this is it's hilarious I want Heidi to
top me see
you know what
I gotta put this phone down
I can't do this
no they get worse
Chase Hudson Rail me challenge
accepted honestly dude next one Heidi
let me eat that ass like a sausage
McGriddle or whatever the Tweet says
what tweet says what well how to eat my
ass like a mince pie at Christmas
Heidi daddy bite me choke me spit on me
step on me I beg
okay I would like to get on my knees and
suck for Chase Hudson
oh my God that's the last one we've made
it we've made it to the very end
this one's the worst
she's Hudson I can't even read this
Chase Hudson I am nothing but a job of
the [__] for you please use your as a
lightsaber to destroy my whole Darth
Vader might be Luke's father but chase
you were my daddy
burn it
just take her phone just honestly just
delete the number I can't even I'm
deleting Twitter now actually
that's crazy
um thank you guys for watching this was
an awesome experience
um I'm questioning everything when you
say things that are on Twitter out loud
blows my mind it's it's crazy thank you
guys for watching check out my new
single slowly healing now available on
Spotify
[Music]